next question today hey David should
underage girls have to have their
rapists babies listen this is very very
simple for me the answer is no okay
is the mother better off having a baby
that they didn't want to have
particularly when they are underage
girls the answer is obviously not is the
baby better off having such a young
parent that they didn't want to have
them to begin with the answer is
obviously no and there are more and more
states as we've been talking about for
the last couple of months in this new
era of a very conservative Supreme Court
thanks to Mitch McConnell's obstruction
of Merrick garland during the Obama
presidency Donald Trump defeating
Hillary Clinton in 2016 and then
appointing two people to the Supreme
Court in this new era of Supreme Court
conservatism there are a lot of
anti-choice activists that are now
starting to put proposals out that say
you do have to have the baby if you are
a victim of rape you do have to have
your rapists baby I am against this but
it's important to understand that a lot
of this is strategy from the right two
weeks ago I believe it was when we
talked about the Georgia and Alabama
bills I pointed out to you that I
believe a lot of conservatives agree
that rape victims particularly underage
girls shouldn't be forced to have their
rapists babies but they are playing the
longer game and they are playing the
game really well which is they want to
get one of these laws contested blocked
by an immediate lower-level Court
appealed all the way to the Supreme
Court of the United States hopefully to
get a Supreme Court ruling that will
contradict roe v wade and allow an
easier path to state-level bans on
abortion so even though there are
definitely some anti-choice people who
genuinely sincerely believe that
underage girls should be forced to carry
to term the babies of their rapists I
think a lot of anti-choice people are
just saying it because they understand
the sort of strategic goal of getting
one of these cases to the Supreme
or in order the further the anti-choice
movement over the long-term now I also
want to point out the reality is that in
practice these laws banning abortion
even in cases of rape will cause more
babies to be born to poor mothers and to
mothers who are not equipped to be
mothers
because wealthy people are going to be
able to continue getting abortion safely
right private clinics that operate
discreetly the ability to travel to
nearby states that haven't banned
abortion those are things that are much
more accessible for middle class upper
middle class and rich people so what you
perpetuate by doing something like
banning exceptions for rape and incest
for example when it comes to abortion
what you perpetuate is mothers having
children who are likely to be poor which
the right claims is bad for society why
are they pushing a policy that would
actually perpetuate more of that it's
all because of this broader strategy of
trying to get something to the Supreme
Court getting a favorable decision that
is anti-abortion and then using that to
justify all sorts of state-level
abortion bans and they're carrying it
out really damn well and we should all
be activating against it and we should
all be making sure that Donald Trump
doesn't get another Supreme Court pick
which would be truly an absolutely
disastrous